and camille there's a weird link to
britain as well because one of your
uh i don't know if you'd call it a
career highlight
but uh you you made a show called
canas which was a kind of a hidden
hidden camera show
yes absolutely and this came to a climax
in london
yes because at the beginning it was just
a short
show for tv it was one minute and a half
and then the two creator
of the show decided they would make a
movie like a one hour and a half movie
and they said okay
what could be the best desire for konas
which is a parisian beach would be their
translation
and they said well marry the prince okay
which prince
is the most glamorous to be married
obviously it was harry because he was
single at the time
so we went and hunted harry
but you you filmed people couldn't see
the cameras but you were in real places
you came to london
and you went to kensington palace yeah
yeah yeah they told me okay now you're
going to climb the
kensington palace fence and you're going
to shout harry and hope that he will
hear you
and i did yeah so presumably
uh police came very quickly no that's
the problem there was this little bobby
in his little cabin
and he was really just in front of the
fence and i thought he would come
immediately but he couldn't hear me
so i literally stayed quite high like
about five minutes which is very long
when you're on the fence of kensington
palace with high heels
and i was shouting harry
hundreds of tourists i mean maybe not
hundreds but let's say 20 tourists
stopped like looking at me and the bobby
never came out i mean he came but like
you know long time after so can i just
say
if someone's sitting in kensington
palace tonight you shouldn't feel that
safe
because the police didn't spot this
woman
because when i heard about it i just
thought oh you were at the bottom kind
of rattling the thing
yeah that was quite embarrassing
you